ben je pense tout simplement que ça peut
être que mieux pour la qualité de l'air
ça c'est une chose 30km ya pas tellement
de voix qui permettent de rouler de
manière beaucoup plus vite ça va
peut-être dégager certaines voix et ça
va peut-être rassuré les cyclistes moi
je suis plutôt je suis plutôt favorable
c'est pas c'est pas un circuit paraît
franchement en étendant j'aurais dit non
suivi l'eau à la base il aurait fait ça
à lille comme je prends du score
évoluera lille sa mort était un peu un
peu relou pour moi mais en soit paris
comme gibier j'ai pas de voiture je
trouve que c'est que du bien et si on
peut tout les tony's et c'est encore
mieux je cours régulièrement sur paris
et j'avoue que c'est on va sur les bords
de seine c'est peut-être le moins pire
mais sinon je pars en campagne pour
courir parce que en pleine piste même
pas imaginable donc voit carrément ça
peut avoir que du positif je suis tout à
fait contre moi parce que la pollution
sera pire parce qu'il ya trente
kilomètres que lorsqu avait d'autres y
aura les embouteillages partout donc le
moto a tourné et ça pollue sur place
peut-être que la mairie de paris veut
donner un truc pour se rallier
ecology terrain il ya beaucoup de
voitures je suis pas sûr que rouler à
32,40 change énormément de choses après
de toute manière à paris on peut pas
rouler normalement très très vite donc
je pense que ça changera pas grand chose
je ne sais pas mais ça sera mieux pour
la sécurité sa scission et 30 km par
rapport à 50 km traverse et pour vous
c'est juste la sécurité
sécurité et puis à bord combat pour
qu'ils aient moins de pollution et
surtout qu'ils aient plus de voitures
quoi plutôt que voudrait dire qu'elle
dure la vitesse est peut-être que dans
dix ans la vitesse il y aura moins de
voitures aussi parce que les gens vous
dire j'ai prévu d'aller à paris voilà
alors moi je pense que déjà 50 c'était
pas super rapide on avait déjà du mal à
les atteindre avec tous les bouchons
dont 30 en fait du jour où ça roule on
aura encore plus de monde voilà ce que
ça change donc aucun avantage je pense
pour les parisiens on aurait fait on
serait passé de 80 à 30 je veux bien
mais 30 à 50 je pense pas qu'une grosse
différence moi je pense que yahia trop
d'embouteillages à paris ça va encore
plus ralentir le trafic donc je sais pas
peut-être pour la pollution c'est
peut-être une meilleure phase où d'un
côté ça va encore plus à faire du trafic
je voudrais plus que les gens passent au
métro vélo tout ça c'est que des
voitures à paris c'est pas très utile je
pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
la circulation et les embouteillages et
puis forcément aussi par rapport à
l'émission de gaz et la pollution donc
je pense que c'est une bonne chose après
moi je n'ai pas de voiture donc je
trouve ça bien mais j'imagine que les
automobilistes sont pas forcément
content mais moi ça me va